hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
fairly on in his short essay plain
persons and moral philosophy Aleister
McIntyre is going to highlight what he
is going to call too closely related
distinctions and he takes these as being
centrally important for moral
development evaluation of ourselves the
narratives that comprise our lives and
you know our making progress towards not
only answering but pursuing the answer
of this question what is my good
McIntyre takes this as being Central to
any sort of you know well thought out
ethics
it's particularly Central in what he's
calling Aristotelian or domestic virtue
ethics but we can find it in in most
others as well the question what is it
that would be good for me what is good
for me as a human being what does my
life center around what goods should I
prioritize and he's telling us a little
bit earlier in this this essay that one
way in which we make sense of this is
what Thomas Aquinas and others would
call inclinations right that's often
translated just as inclinations and he
tells us that here it is
these normed govern directed misses are
what Aquinas calls inclination and so
you know part of his affective part of
it can also be cognitive but we are
directed towards certain things we don't
need to go into any great detail about
that you can check out Thomas Aquinas
and and there's many discussions of that
in McIntyre so in clinician s are one
way in which we grasp this another is
what he calls practices and this is
really a central Concept in McIntyre's
philosophy and he says that this is
um a way in which individuals raise or
have raised the question what is my good
a manner that's complementary to that in
which the question is posed by
inclinationes and so he calls this a
type of activity characteristic of
practices what are these Cooperative
forms of activity whose participants
jointly pursue Goods internal to these
forms of activity and jointly value
excellence in achieving these Goods so
not every single thing that we do is a
practice there have to be internal Goods
to it he gives you examples the
activities of members of string quartets
right they're getting together to play
some music they're not just bsing or
playing role-playing games or canning
vegetables they're they're actually
doing this thing here which then has its
own standards for what comprises
Excellence playing the music well being
able to be in the same tempo with the
other people that you're practicing and
then eventually performing with he gives
other examples Crews of fishing fleets
Architects and construction workers
jointly engaged in developing good
housing members of families making and
sustaining the family familial Community
farmers and physicists these are all as
he says practice based and practiced
structured so again lots of other things
to say about practices but we're mainly
just setting the scene here for these
distinctions so McIntyre goes on a
little bit further and he says that it's
by our finding application for a
teleological scheme a goal Direct acted
scheme of understanding in our practical
activities a scheme which provides the
directedness of our inclinationes with a
further rationale that we first become
evidently if even if unwittingly
aristotelians it is doing so we acquire
a capacity for becoming reflective about
norms and goals now this doesn't have to
be by reading Thomas Aquinas or
Aristotle you could have never read a
philosophy book in your life and yet
developed this capacity for being
reflective about norms and goals you
know to take the string quartet if
somebody is playing too loudly it could
be what are you doing buddy and they can
be like well I just want to make sure
that I'm actually being heard and you
can be like so here's the way a string
quartet works we all get our times to be
heard but we're supposed to you know
work together on this and then they say
oh I didn't realize that was what the
goal really was I mean I do still have
the goal of being heard actually I
understand now all of you do too but
here's the way in which we do it
according to these Norms internal to the
practice right so we developed these
capacities for figuring out how to
answer this question concretely
practically within groups and
communities
and then McIntyre says well this leads
us to two important interrelated moral
distinctions
and again something that I think we can
find at many points in his other work
this is a great article for introducing
some key mcintyreen ideas
so he says the first of these
distinctions is that between what I
would do if I did what would please me
most here and now and now please doesn't
necessarily mean you know physical
pleasure it's what I would actually
enjoy the most Here and Now what I would
value the most here and now and then on
the other side
um what I would do if now notice this
Proviso in the light of the best
instruction available to me I were to do
what would make me excellent in the
pursuit of the goods internal to the
particular practice or practices in
which I'm engaged now why do we have to
make that distinction a lot of people
don't and they think that oh you know if
I just do what I enjoy Here and Now what
what I find most interesting compelling
attractive then that will result in me
being excellent so you get a lot of
amateur musicians who never get any good
because they're not willing to put in
the time the discipline the work of
doing all the practice stuff to build up
their skills and they just want to play
songs you know and they they never
actually
progress towards those goods internal to
those
practices right and we could come up
with all sorts of other distinctions he
mentioned family life right it's quite
easy if you're a parent to say you know
I just want us all to get along and I
want to be friends with my kids but
that's not what all parenting is I mean
ideally you do actually have friendships
with your children but that has to
develop over time and you know in light
of the best information that I have you
could say well what would actually make
me excellent in pursuit of the goods
internal to the practices those goods
might be providing for your children's
own development and health and other
things well and so in order to be
excellent as a parent that way you you
have to you know you can't just do what
would please you here and now I mean we
could think about very simple things
like should you cook food at home that's
healthy and where you know where the
ingredients are coming from or should
you you always just order in I mean it's
easier to order in not cheaper to order
in
but there's some excellences that come
from the practices of cooking not just
for yourself but for others as well so
now he says failure in making this first
distinction is characteristically a sign
of failure in a determinate field in
ordering the appetites and passions so
the appetites are desires that he's
using
um a sort of Aristotelian domestic
terminology there think about your
desires your things that you're also
averse to and then the passions the
passions are the emotions right so
McIntyre is using a slightly archaic
vocabulary here
not making this distinction well is a
sort of failure in becoming excellent in
a number of ways so you know a
prerequisite to that is learning how to
control all your appetites and not a
spawn not respond emotionally all the
time to call your emotional responses
into question and doesn't mean you have
to turn your emotions off or anything
like that then he says the second
distinction
this is very interesting now it's a
little bit hard to read this McIntyre
sometimes his style gets confusing
between what it would be to achieve what
is good and best uncle qualifiably we'll
come back to that in a moment and what
is good and best here and now for me at
my stage in the education of my
capacities to do so what is he saying
there what it would be to achieve what
is good and best unqualifiedly what is
the ideal
uh limit point or end or goal not just
for me but for anybody else who's in my
sort of situation broadly speaking so
again let's take musical performance
what would it be for me as a musician
I'm an amateur musician to
um realize my good to achieve what is
good and best unqualifiedly I can
project what it would be like for me and
it would take a very long time for me to
reach that if I could and indeed do it
but I can imagine that for myself right
and I can imagine that for myself as a
parent just to use some of the other
examples I don't Farm you know but I
have had Gardens and I could imagine
what that would be like for me as
somebody who engages with a plot of land
over time cares for it harvests it weeds
it all those sorts of things so that's
one thing over here
now we can also say what is it that
would is good and best
here and now for me at my stage of
Education or moral development what
would be the good and best for me to do
and so this is a very important
distinction and some people blur these
together and get them quite confused
they think that you don't you know need
any sort of Ideal like this to give you
an uh you know a sense of where you
could be going I'm just going to focus
on what's good and best for me right now
I'm very pragmatic or they can go the
other way and they can be like if I
can't achieve this then this other stuff
over here is just crap it's not good
it's not best because it's not the best
or the highest good and therefore it's
valueless but McIntyre wants to say no
no no no
how you actually develop this capacity
for becoming reflective about your norms
and goals better and better and better
is by making this distinction by holding
these two different things in mind at
the same time and he says that when you
fail at this
it's characteristically a sign of
failure in evaluating how far I've
progressed in ordering these appetites
and passions so both distinctions are
actually dealing with appetites and
passions or we could say desires and
aversions and emotions right and how we
how we understand how we deal with them
but they're doing it in somewhat
different ways and McIntyre brings us to
a close by saying how to make these
distinctions is something each person
has to learn
and what has to be learned can always be
mislearned we can get these distinctions
wrong because maybe other people or our
culture gives us the wrong take on these
so he says through a process of learning
making mistakes correcting these
mistakes moving towards the achievement
of Excellence the individual comes to
understand themselves as in via meaning
on the road in the middle of a journey
right so it's these are distinctions
that inevitably McIntyre thinks
everybody either makes or they screw up
and either make badly or don't make at
all but you can't really get away from
them so this is why he wants to
highlight them here in this essay